[Music]
Healthcare is a humongous economic
engine it's often forgotten about the
fact that there is a real contribution
to the economy by health care if you're
running a large health care organization
you're probably the place that is doing
the most construction in the region so
for example in our organization we do
more construction than anybody else if
you want to be in the healthcare
business and you want to be in the
laundry business we have the largest
laundry service if you want to be in
maintenance we have a probably one of
the largest maintenance shops in the
region the dietary business just imagine
the amount of meals that are provided in
a hospital every day more meals that are
provided in any restaurant then you can
think about here in Manhattan every
single day seven days a week so if you
want to be in the dietary business in
the food business health care is a job
growth area this is not the point I'm
trying to make it is not just a business
that only takes care of the medical
treatment of a person who comes in who
is ill it's all of the other ancillary
business so whatever occupation that you
want to be in you can find it inside
healthcare if you're in a poor community
and you have a hospital and some people
will say maybe that Hospital in that
community is not doing that well but
also remember that it is the largest
employment source in that community and
that's why you often get into a
discussion about well maybe that
hospital should be downsized maybe that
Hustle should be closed and there are
reasons to argue those points in certain
circumstances but you also have to face
with the reality that in those cases
that place is the only place that hires
people from that community so if that
facility closes that or no jobs in that
community therefore that community which
is the private at the moment will only
be more deprived if the hospital closes
so it's just not only health care alone
that you're looking at it's all of the
surrounding issues that are connected to
the direct provision of health care
services
[Music]